[Music]
welcome to a debate which is called the
rise and fall of sex although most of us
are critical of gender stereotypes few
deny the existence of two discrete
biological sexes yet contemporary
biology shows human sex currently
reduced to a simple story about X and y
chromosomes and some neuroscience claims
that there's no such thing as a gendered
brain either could biological sex itself
then be an illusion constructed from
human categories can we overcome or
refashion these categories to suit 21st
century needs or is this a futile
attempt to deny the reality of two
biological sexes I'm going to introduce
our panelists on my right Barry Barnes
who is a sociologist and co-founder of
the influential strong program an
approach to the sociology of scientific
knowledge described by inheritors such
as Bruno Latour as unparalleled in its
importance for the field Barry is also
member and former co-director of the
center for genomics in society at the
University of Exeter where he examines
the impact of inter subjective agreement
and society on genetics on my immediate
left
Daphne Joelle Daphna is a neuroscientist
and senior member of the Faculty of
school of psychological sciences at tel
aviv university
she is the author of a forthcoming book
called gender mosaic beyond the myth of
male and female brains which argues that
our current ideas about biological say
need to be challenged and presents a
theory that male and female brains are
not different by nature and finally on
my far left stuart richie who's a
lecturer at King's College London at the
university's social genetic and
developmental psychiatry Center his
writings appeared in The Washington Post
why'd he on etc on topics ranging from
IQ tests mean anything and to peer
reviewing he recently conducted a study
to examine sex differences in the adult
human brain coming to the conclusion
that the brains of men and women differ
in the same way as their height and
stature
so those are our three panelists I think
we're in for a lively debate here so
without further ado I'm going to turn to
you Barry and that I think the
overarching question we're asking here
at the beginning is could biological sex
itself be an illusion
constructed from human categories I'm
looking over at Barry's notes the title
of his notes a sex pitch mainly about
genetics when we get to the debate
because it's long being my own in focus
of interest when looking at the sciences
biological sex in particular has
interested me now way back in 1967 the
sex of a newborn was fixed by visual
inspection and a register of births
certified its status or meal made as
male or female tall they were allowed to
do but sighted geneticists at this time
had begun to use a quick and simple test
to determine the genetic sex they did
thousands of applications of this simple
thing mostly were normal cases but they
they identified quite a few anomalous
ones by use of the genetic tests and
that made the genetics of sex much more
complicated than it had been and
researchers realized that conveying what
they knew have sex two others have
become at the same time much more
difficult and much more important now of
course it couldn't have been predicted
then that in just a few decades we would
live in a world where there in sex is
mostly referred to as gender and
genetics is mostly molecular genetics
I've watched accounts of genetic sex
become ever more detailed and complex
over a long period and I've seen nothing
to suggest that sex as biological sex is
an illusion although it has been said
and is being said in another debate that
the world's all an illusion and how
would we know if it were as two entries
on birth certificates however they are
neither empirical
descriptions like a empirical science
would make nor are they illusions which
seems to be the only alternative that
comes to the mind of many people their
statuses their attributions of status
that indicate to other members of
society how they ought to treat the
person designated and assigned and if
other statuses join will replace those
in current use
nothing changes they're still all
statuses they don't describe empirical
States even if they're based on
empirical States now it may be that the
registrar's of tomorrow in a more
tolerant society are going to do an
awful lot better assigning sex statuses
than those who long ago assigned a sex
to an intersex newborn and kept that
assignation confidential but even they
did no more long ago than attach the
status to a child and act with her mind
to how she was treated in the future we
need to understand statuses thank you
very much so it's a story of increasing
complexity in our understanding in
general but this concept of the status
is what's key to what you're arguing
thank you very much Daphna let me come
to you
so there's a short answer to the
question as the short answer is I don't
think that biological sex is an illusion
but I do think that our binary
conceptualization of sex is an illusion
and the long answer is that this is a
tricky question
because we use biological sex for at
least two different meanings we use
biological sex sex to describe the
divisions of humans into a sex
categories male and female according to
the form of the genitalia by imposing a
binary division on on the form of the
genitalia we ignore or we mistreat
individuals that do not fit into one of
these categories so whereas most humans
or most of humans genitalia do fit into
the categories because they have only
made typical organs or only female
typical organs some humans don't now the
other meaning that we use biological sex
is to relate to all the genes and
hormones that are involved in the
formation of the genitalia and they of
course exist these genes and hormones
but the binary frame will framework
misleads us to believe that these genes
and hormones are arranged in two
distinct sets what one appearing in
males and the other appearing with
females and this is simply not true so
except from a few genes on the Y
chromosomes all humans share all the
genes and the hormones that are involved
in the formation of the genitalia and
they these genes and hormones especially
the hormones are highly dynamic highly
reactive highly overlapping between
humans and they clearly do not come in
two distinct form like the genitalia do
now these genes and hormones affect not
just genitalia but also other systems
and one of them is the brain and again
the the a binary framework miss leads us
to believe that sex effects on the day
on the brain add up consistently within
individuals as sex effects on the
genitalia often does to create distinct
male brain and female brains and this
again is not true because sex effects on
the brain usually mix up so each one of
us has feature
in the brains that are more common in
males in others that are more common in
females so zone sex
affects the brain and although there are
group level differences between the
brains of men and women they do not
adapt to create male brains and female
brains but rather mosaic brains thank
you very much so going back to your
early phrase there something maybe the
sex isn't an illusion but the binary
construct is perhaps an illusion okay
thank you
that's true it let me just push back
slightly on the binary thing and
obviously this is a topic which everyone
gets very upset about and it totally is
understandable because as both Barry and
Athena said we talked about sex in terms
of this thing which we study in the lab
and also in terms of this thing which is
super important in society and it's how
we label people and it's it's often how
we treat people as well so it's
completely understandable there's a lot
of bad feeling around this topic people
on both sides you know people who argue
against the importance of sex
differences get accused of being sex
difference deniers and or sex deniers or
gender or whatever they want to call
them and people on the other side get
accused of being sexist sand neural
sexist sand and so on so there's all
sort of epithets going back and forth on
this and but the question is what is the
actual data say so I've been interested
for a little while in differences in the
brain and we took a one of the largest
samples of people that's ever been
gathered all together the UK biobank
sample last year and we published a
paper that showed that there were indeed
very large differences in things like
brain volume brain surface area brain
the cortical thickness or the thickness
of the outside of the brain between
people who identified as male and people
who identified as female just people who
just checked it on the form we're not
talking about a genetic test here we're
just what people say about themselves
and there were large differences females
had Vicker cortices which is associated
with for instance things like having a
higher intelligence males had larger
volumes which is also associated with
having a higher intelligence so it's
kind of there's there's one for both
sides there and and and and but but
perhaps more interesting than my study
which is actually quite a boring paper
more interesting is is when people look
across all the differences they add up
all
the differences and see how good you are
if you just have someone's brain how
accurately can you build a model that
would predict whether they had said they
were male or said they were female to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas